I am the man the man with a plan fix the  economy yes I can't balance the books  you yes you i I want to be Chancellor -  I plan for the many not the privileged  few this is what our labor budget will  do Falls bed like George said you want  Britain's support to be instead we're on  the road to prosperity we are on the  right you will see the job through and  get back to the black kids the deck is  stacked the game is wound in favor of  those who have all the power we will  raise the minimum wage to over eight  pounds an hour fixing fixing fixing  fixing brittle shattered economy fixing  fixing fixing fixing Britain's shattered  economy